وغير انعدام الضمير المتعلق بالبناء او
النهب او السرقه شفنا مقطع الانعدام اخلاق
وضمير من نوع مختلف تماما القياده بمليشيا
الحشد الشعبي في العراقي لسابع لايران عبد
العزيز المحمداوي الملقب بالخال او ابو
فدك السيد الفاضل هذا هو في زيارته
لمحافظه حلب يعني قال انه يعني ضمن حمله
مساعدات بيقدمها الحشد يعني
الزلزال في سوريا خلينا نسمع بالله ايش
لقطته الكاميرات وهو بيقول
الضابط اي وحده متاخره او فاتها القطار
بتمشي عندنا
بوحد مو عارف صراحه ايش يقول يعني بعيدا
عن الازمه الانسانيه والكارثه والزلزال
والموتى والناس اللي يعني حوالينه تحت
الانقاض بعيدا عن كل هذا الكلام اللي قاله
كارثه لوحده بكل المقاييس يعني فكيف في
ضمن السياق اللي اصلا الوضع العام في كله
وايش بالنسبه للابتسامه اللي على وشه يعني
في وسط هذا الدمار ولا ضحكه اللي حوالينه
على النكته اللي ما حتى نقدر نوصفها
بالبايخه لانها يعني مقززه ومقرفه حتى
يعني في يعني ولها اوصاف تانيه كمان اسوا
بكثير يعني الصراحه شيء مقزز فعلا
[موسيقى]